بوتين. ان الحل الوحيد لمنع
محاصرة مقاطعة كالينجراد الروسية
يهدف له بوتين من هذه الاسلحة
فعلا. يرد رئيس بلاروسيا الكسندر
ان قواتها نفذت كمينا وصفته
بالناجح استهدف القوات الروسية
والامريكان بتقدم بكين عليهم.
فهل تسمح واشنطن باستمرار الوضع
وعزلها عن روسيا من قبل دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي هو الغزو
وتقلل النرويج من شأن مطالب
موسكو لانها ترى انه لا يوجد
ايران تطلق صاروخا بحثيا بنجاح
الى الفضاء. موسكو تعد خطة
خلاف على ان الجزيرة ارض تابعة
لها. اندريه جورليو حليف مقرب من
الروسية في اوكرانيا التلويح
بالذهاب لفرض مزيد من العقوبات
روسيا وسوريا تجريان تدريبات
عسكرية مشتركة لقوات المظلات.
للتوصل الى اي حل تفاوضي الان في
اوكرانيا وقالت جونسون انه يجب
تحالفات بالمحيط الهادئ لصد
بكين. قال الرئيس الاوكراني
بين الناتو وروسيا ستكون اكثر
سوءا. انتزعت القوات العسكرية
فقال ان مجموعة السبع تتعهد
بالحياد الكربوني بحلول الفين
جزيرة سبيتس بيرجين نقطة روسيا
ونقطة ضعف الناتو فما هي هذه
في ارخبيل سفالبارد موسكو تعتبر
الجزيرة جزءا من التاريخ الروسي
بالنتو باكمله في كل مكان وبنسبة
مائة بالمائة. ثالثا بالتأكيد لن
خطوات من شأنها حظر التعامل
بالذهب الروسي الذي يعتبر ثاني
اقتصادياتنا بالطاقة الروسية
ونود عزل روسيا واقناع الدول
التصديرية المهمة. فهل تقدر هذه
الدول على هذه الخطة وبماذا سترد
خطة بوتين لم تأتي عبثا بل ردا
على نشر واشنطن مائتي رأس نووي
الروسي لن يدخل اوروبا بعد
اليوم. فمن يأخذه. كييف تنتزع
امدادات الغاز بعدما تراجعت
تدفقات الغاز الروسي عبر خط
لوكاشينكو يجب علينا التأهب لكل
شيء بما في ذلك استخدام الاسلحة
في منطقة زابروتشيا الجنوبية.
واسفر عن مقتل ثلاثمائة جندي
على روسيا. دراسة جديدة
الامريكيون يرون ان نفوذ بلادهم
بلا روسيا صواريخ قادرة على حمل
شحنات نووية. الصواريخ من طراز
لمواجهة الناتو والغرب يحضرون
عقوبات اكثر بين الغرب وروسيا
عربة مدرعة وثماني قاذفات صواريخ
متعددة بنيران اسلحة عالية الدقة
فان القنبلة العملاقة اسقطت على
مبنى سكني في حي سالتيف قبل
نبدأ من وارسو او باريس او برلين
ستكون لندن اول من يتم ضربها.
بتدمير مجموعة الاقمار الصناعية
للعدو خلال العملية الجوية
اكبر الصادرات الروسية بعد النفط
في السوق العالمية وذلك لحرمان
اوديسا على البحر الاسود. قالت
قيادة عمليات الجنوب الاوكراني.
قنبلة روسية لم تنفجر تزن نصف
طن. فماذا لو انفجرت حليف مقرب
بوتين الاستراتيجي. ونقطة ضعف
الناتو. سبيتس برجن اكبر جزيرة
فولودي ميرزلنسكي ان اوكرانيا
ستستعيد جميع المدن التي استطاعت
ما اعلنت رئاسة الحكومة
البريطانية. واكد رئيس الوزراء
تجري لعبة القط والفأر ولعبة شد
الحبل. فالى اي طرف ستميل الكفة
مائتين وعشرين مبنى سكنيا على
رؤوس ساكنيها منذ بداية الحرب.
الاولى. وثانيا سنضرب منظومات
الدفاع المضاد للصواريخ الخاص
مباشرا لامن وقيم دول الحلف وليس
لدينا نية لنشر اسلحة نووية في
روسي. واكدت القوات الاوكرانية
استمرار تقدمها باتجاه مواقع
انجاحها يجب اجراء مناقشات صادقة
حقا بشأن تداعيات ما يحدث
الغاز تماما عنها. الاحداث
والتطورات. رسالتان خرجت بهما
لبوتين يشرح خطة الحرب ضد الناتو
وبريطانيا اول دولة سيتم قصفها؟
امدادات الغاز قد تصل الى تجمد
المنازل في الشتاء القادم في ظل
الاسلحة النووية. اذ سيضع طائرات
اس يو خمسة وعشرين في خدمة
الاوكرانية بمساعدة فرق الانقاذ
قنبلة يبلغ وخمسمائة كيلو جرام
الانابيب الرئيسي في اوروبا
بنسبة ستين بالمئة. مخاطر قطع
انعقاد مؤتمر الدول السبع اعلنت
الولايات المتحدة وبريطانيا عن
وخمسين. وسنمنع روسيا من استخدام
الغاز سلاح ضدنا. مجازر
توليد الطاقة فكيف ستتصرف
المانيا اذا اغلق بوتين صنبور
الامين العام لحلف الناتو يانس
تولتنبرغ روسيا باتت تشكل تهديدا
شتاء قارص البرودة بسبب روسيا
يخشى اكبر اقتصاد اوروبي خفض
الروسي لدول البلطيق التابعة
لحلف شمال الاطلسي. اولا سنقوم
اسقطت جوا على سطح مبنى سكني في
خركيف وبحسب المعلومات الاولية
اوروبا الشرقية. الحرب بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا وحشية لكن الحرب
كي تحمي محادثات مع موسكو يا
ترى. قرارات غربية حاسمة. قبل
على مصنع ميجا تكس للزنك في في
دونتسك. عمدة كييف اكثر من
انه قتل نحو ثمانين من المرتزقة
البولنديين في قصف ودمر عشرين
اقل من اربعة اشهر تصل برلين الى
الشتاء مع انعدام الغاز الروسي
التمركز الروسية في ريف زبروشيا.
من ناحية اخرى قال الجيش الروسي
ثلاثة اشهر واخترقت سطحا. جزيرة
اعتبرها الخبراء سر فلاديمير
بوتين كان يراهن على انقسام
الغرب ومجموعة سبع ولكن ذلك لن
اكثر فتكا. اذا على الناتو ان
يستعد لهذه الحرب. بريطانيا
روسيا احتلالها بما في ذلك
سيفيرو دونك. بدوره افاد الجيش
هكذا? وطهران تطلق صاروخا الى
الفضاء. كرم بوتين النووي. اعلن
المتحدة الامريكية للمساعدة في
حماية السواحل الاوكرانية في
روسيا من عشرات المليارات من
الدولارات من عائدات هذه السلعة
الاقتصاد. بوتين يهدد اكبر
اقتصاد في اوروبا. المانيا تترقب
القوات المسلحة لبلاروسيا. وبدأ
التدريب على استخدامها. فما الذي
واما المستشار الالماني الذي
تستضيف بلاده قمة مجموعة سبع
يتراجع امام تقدم الصين مع
تحركات مكثفة لواشنطن لعمل
قمة الدول السبع تشكيل موقف موحد
من قبل القادة المجتمعين الحرب
ما يجعلها تتجه لخطة بديلة
كالعودة للاعتماد على الفحم في
البريطاني جونسون لصحفيين من اجل
حماية هذه الوحدة. ومن اجل
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
بلاده ستسلم في الاشهر المقبلة
ويا لها من معركة طاحنة يا
اصدقائي. بينما قال بايدن ان
بعدم بناء تحالفات معها وتلك
معركة سياسية على الساحة الدولية
ارتفاع تكاليف الطاقة والغذاء
لكن ثمن السماح لروسيا بالفوز
يحدث ولن يحدث ابدا. مشددا على
ان هناك الكثير لنفعله لمواجهة
الجزيرة؟ زيلنسكي يتعهد باستعادة
المدن التي خسرها. فكيف له ذلك؟
والضغوط التي يشعر بها الاصدقاء
والشركاء. فما الذي ستفعله لندن
على زعماء العالم ان يدرك ان
هناك ثمنا لدعم اوكرانيا يشمل
التحديات الاقتصادية جراء
الاعتداء الروسي على اوكرانيا.
موسكو? رئيس المجلس الاوروبي
علينا ان نواجه تحديات ارتباط
تهاجم. حذر رئيس وزراء بريطانيا
بوريس جونسون من اي محاولة
سيكون بكثير لان ذلك سيؤدي الى
ازمة اقتصادية طويلة الامد وفق
في ست دول اوروبية هي اعضاء في
الناتو. دعم بوتين لن يقتصر على
الاوكراني بوصول ست سفن حربية
وثمانية عشر زورقا من الولايات
تكرهها اوروبا بصواريخ تحمل
رؤوسا نووية. فمن هي هذه الدولة؟
يا ترى?
السبع تظهر مفاجأتها للعلن في
اجتماعهم حول روسيا والذهب
المانيا تستنجد والسبب روسيا
وكرم بوتين النووي يدعم دولة
بريطانيا تهاجم روسيا بشكل صريح.
فهل يرد بوتين على ذلك؟ الدول